All right. Let's get started, and thank you for
attending this early phase design methodology workshop.
And
as many of you know,
innovative trial design, it's one of the most cost-effective way
to enhance efficiency and success
of clinical research. And in the past few years, the
FDA released a serious guidance
encouraging practice use of
innovative trial design to improve drug development.
However, in practice, many of those approaches
are quite complicated to implement, and severely limited
their use in practice.
So the goal of this workshop is to introduce a
framework called mode assist design, which
is easy to implement and at the same time, maintain rigorous
statistical efficiency. And we have three
speakers. Can I have next?
So I'm going to introduce three big speaker
all at the beginning so we can have a
talk in a very smooth way. So our speaker,
first one is
Dr. Mangiaarca, and she's a highly respected leader in
clinical design and conduct. And she's a professor of biostatistics,
oncology in the Mayo Clinic, and the program director
of the Statistical and Data Management Center for the Alliance for Clinical Trial
in Oncology. And she's widely recognized for her
contribution to statistical methodology for design, conduct,
and analysis of clinical trial, particularly in oncology.
And also for her leadership in clinical trials and the data management
coordination.
Also, she leads a lot of program, national and international
steering committee, and wider committee related to cancer research.
And she currently co-chairs NCI steering clinical
trial implement committee, and she's a fellow and past
president of the Society for Clinical Trial and on the statistical
board for the New England Journal of Medicine Evidence. So Dr.
Mangiaarca has published over 190 peer-reviewed publication,
that including innovative designs for phase one, two, and three
clinical trial.
So our second speaker is Dr. Philip Hee,
and he is a statistician at Daiichi Sankyo, and with
two decades of experience in oncology drug development,
span early phase trials through regulatory approval.
He has led a statistical team in the successful development of multiple
cancer therapies, including chemotherapy,
tyrosine kinase inhibitor, monoclonal antibody, and
immunotherapy.
And passionate about advanced oncology development, Dr.
Hee actively contributed to scientific communities through service
in various professional organization.
And for example, he serves as head of early
phase statistics,
and the co-chair of the
DASU Innovative Design and the Scientific Workshop in
Oncology group.
And he also contributed to our community as an editor
and editorial board member in Therapeutic Innovation Regular
Science and the New England Journal of Statistical and Data Science.
So last speaker is myself, and I'm
Betty Anne Ash Murray, distinguished professor and the chair of
Department of Biostatistics at MD Anderson Cancer Center.
So I have done quite a bit of work in bayes adaptive design,
including early phase stimulus design, hybrid
control design, and information borrowing.
So our lab developed a website called
trialdesign.org, and I think perhaps many of
you have used it. And
among those designs, the borrowing design, it's a groundbreaking oncology
dose-finding design recognized by the FDA as a fit for purpose
drug tool.
And, so I'm a member of FDA Advisory Committee for Genetic
Metabolic Disease and wrote some book regarding
early phase design.
So okay. And for our session, each speaker going to have
about 30 minutes. So the plan is going to have a
20-minute speech followed by a 10 minutes Q&A.
And okay, so without further ado, let's get started.
Thank you, Ying, and thank you everybody for coming to this session.
Also want to thank AACR for organizing and putting together
this session. I'm looking forward to the discussion and
all the talks as much as all of you are.
So I think the workshop itself really talks about simplicity meeting
efficiency in the early phase setting.
So I will focus more on what do we do in an
early phase clinical trial? How much data are we collecting, how complex it is, and
how do we make sense of all of the data we collect to make informed decisions
for dose optimization?
My disclosure information. All right.
So early phase trials, the characteristics I have that
listed on the slide, but beyond that, I think I want to start off with saying
that the early phase trials form the foundation for the path of clinical
trial development, right? It is the first step we take when we want to bring
forward a therapy into the clinic.
So it's very important, and that's why there is a lot of emphasis on how do
you design these trials appropriately, especially with the changing landscape of
treatments in cancer. So the real question becomesHow much
information are you collecting? How informative is this information?
And how, without hurrying up, are you using all of this information in
an informed way to make the
next decision? So really it's the foundation, if I can say that,
for trials in the landscape. So
the basic trial characteristics we all know, right?
The goal is to identify a safe and tolerable dose,
treating cohorts of patients at escalating dose levels, and using dose-limiting
toxicity to really understand what's a safe dose.
But often we probably ignore the richness of the toxicity data.
I'll talk a little bit about it. We don't probably often spend enough time
understanding the efficacy readout in early phase trials.
So in the past, we were doing only dose escalation.
Then it was called a dose expansion, but now we have a different term.
Almost always you see in all early phase
trials, the concept of dose optimization.
So dose optimization really means you have identified a set of tolerable
dose levels, but now you want to really understand a bit more.
Like, what is the best schedule?
Do you do a fixed dosing? Do you want to understand the mode of administration?
Are there certain subsets of patients who may benefit or may have a better
efficacy readout or tolerate this dose a little bit differently than
everybody else? Then there's PRO data.
So there's all of this additional information that you spend a little bit more time
in early phase to actually understand. So dose optimization, right?
So why dose optimization?
There's multiple levels of toxicity data that's collected in phase one.
As I always say, it's both the length and the breadth.
So there is different types of toxicity information that you collect, and
also how long you're treating the patient, how much cumulative toxicity
they accumulate. So you also want to gather information on the
delays, discontinuations, and reductions, because oftentimes the dose that you move
from an early phase to a phase two or a phase three, you realize,
especially because I do trials in all setting,
you see sometimes you bring forward a dose level from a phase one and you do a
non-inferiority in a phase three, and you have
patients that are not able to tolerate the dose, and so they don't even stay
on the treatment beyond one or two cycles.
So clearly the non-inferiority margin and anything that you're trying to understand
in a phase three, you cannot do because you just don't have the right dose that
you're giving to the patient. So it's very important to understand the delays,
discontinuations, interruptions, and reductions.
And then, of course, we want to understand any of these safe doses, do they
actually benefit the patient? What's the benefit-risk ratio?
And are there homogeneous subgroups?
Are there frail patients who may need a different type
of dosing, intermittent dosing, for example? Is it histology focused?
Is it biomarker defined? And often, we
don't do this a lot in early phase trials, but I have, towards the end of my
presentation, I'll try to help you understand why it's very important to also start
to focus on patient-reported outcomes, on how are
they perceiving
their toxicity or efficacy that they're receiving in that treatment.
So dose optimization all around very important because we have to identify
doses and schedules not just for that trial, but for moving it through the clinical
trial space. So you have to know that these doses and schedules that you're
identifying in the early phase, they're able to tolerate long-term, it's
improving adherence. Patients have to be compliant to be able to derive the
benefit, and ultimately, does it improve the overall outcomes
in terms of survival or
other outcomes in cancer?
So data used in dose optimization. Again, I'm going to go back.
It's the tolerability. We don't do a great
job today of really understanding the full spectrum of the toxicity data we
collect on patients in phase one trials.
How much information do we use on the relationship to the treatment?
Do we pay attention to when the event occurs?
What are the different types of AEs?
Are there different grades of adverse events, the patient's experience?
Because we almost always focus on what's called a serious adverse events, but
we have trials where patients are dropping out, not for serious adverse events, but
multiple mild toxicities. They're unable to take even the
grade two rash that continues for multiple cycles, and
they go off
the treatment.
And then I already spoke about this.
And then efficacy can be clinical outcomes like progression,
survival, tumor shrinkage, or it could be any bio-- If you have a
good understanding of the molecular features
of this target, maybe even understanding that at the early
stage is important. And patient-reported outcomes, it doesn't have to be just
quality of life, but it's also how are the patients' interpretation
of the toxicity they are experiencing in the trial.
That's very important because
most of what we have talked about designs are really
clinician-assessed adverse events.
When a patient presents to you in the clinic.
But really there's a patient perception of these, the PRO CTCAEs,
which it was
somewhat in its nascency before, but now it's widely used, at least in the late
phase trials. And I think there is a space for bringing it to earlier phase
trials.
So focusing on adverse events, very simple.
If you don't want to even focus on, okay, are there certain adverse events
I want to focus on in the early phase trial, or do I want to look at the whole
spectrum of adverse? So it's very simple.
So you really just take everything that the patient experiences in a cycle
and you just compute a score. And however long they are on treatment,
you can either do a total or you can do an average, depending on number of
cycles that they take.
The only downfall of this is
how do I weight the different toxicities?
You grade them today with the CTCAs, maybe just use the grade.
So it's not very difficult to come up with a score
that actually is encompassing all of their toxicity
experience in the early phase setting.So then you
can figure out what a worse score should be, right?
Everything that's grade four or grade five, so you can normalize those scores.
It's not difficult to do all of that.
Then you do a total toxicity profile. It's zero to one.
It incorporates, like I said, the length and breadth, the different types, and how
long they are on treatment, multiple cycles of treatment, multiple grades, multiple
types, everything into the score.
And then you create two sub-models, one for toxicity, which is really our
dose escalation phase. Obviously, our first and foremost
outcome in a dose-finding or an early phase trial is to make sure it's safe.
So definitely the dose escalation phase goes first, because if the
treatment is not even tolerable, we don't want to go
anywhere beyond. It doesn't matter if it's efficacious, right?
If we can't tolerate it. So then you have the efficacy model for
the dose optimization. And then you identify the doses that are both safe
and
provide some sort of a benefit-risk ratio for the patient.
So we can incorporate data from multiple treatment cycles.
We can look at continuous efficacy outcome, could be quality of life,
clinical biomarker. You can incorporate mild, moderate toxicities.
You can incorporate late toxicities.
You can incorporate all of this information.
So simple, right? Most of us, when we think of phase one trials
and if you think of our regular three plus three. Okay.
So one out of three patients, I want to add three more patients, two out of six.
What do I say? Very algorithmic designs.
But even here, you want to know what a toxicity threshold has to be, right?
You can't come in with a score and say, "Now what
does 0.28 mean?" So, we have to think about
what's the worst experience a patient can have for this particular
regimen, and we can come up with a score, between zero and one, that
we think is not tolerable. I just put 0.28. You can do 0.35, 0.5.
Depends on if this is in a hematologic setting and
they have a lot of heme adverse events, maybe you don't want to consider that.
Maybe you only consider the non-heme adverse events, and then you can come up with
a score. So there's many ways to develop this score. Now that's the score.
And then over time, like I was saying, every patient, we don't just give one
cycle of treatment to the patient when they get onto the phase twos and the phase
threes. They are exposed to multiple cycles of treatment.
So obviously, the repeated exposure of that treatment to the patient is
going to result
in continuous accumulation of toxicity burden for the patient.
So that's what these are showing. So as you go from cycle one, cycle
two, cycle three, cycle four, cycle five, cycle six, as the cycles go, even
though the dose that you have identified is dose two for this first
curve, as these patients are exposed to more and
more cycles, that's going to shift.
So there's expected toxicity with the increasing time trend, and of course,
efficacy patterns, we don't know what that is.
Depends on what the dose range is, and then within that dose range.
This is showing across all dose levels.
But really when are you using this is when you identify your dose range.
Maybe there's really no difference in all the dose range for efficacy.
Maybe within those three or four dose levels, there is some sort of a pattern that
you can expect. So that's all this is saying.
So the dose-finding algorithm itself then goes first
step, you have a dose escalation using multiple cycles of toxicity data.
At the end of stage one, you'll probably identify a set of allowable dose
levels. Now, this is using this multi-dimensional kind of nature for the
toxicity.
You get into the dose optimization phase, which is, okay, I have a set of dose
levels I think is safe based on my toxicity profile.
Now I want to explore what are those dose levels that are going to give me the most
efficacy. And then at the end of the
trial, you have all of the information that you use to make an informed
decision on using the complete data on what's the lowest dose that is
also efficacious.
So we have a package, it's called a phase one RMD.
It's an R package for repeated measures dose-finding designs.
It implements this. It uses the multidimensional toxicity endpoint.
It uses data from multiple cycles, multiple types, and also
incorporates efficacy.
It has a flexible cohort size. You can have algorithmic constraints on
the dose escalation. Sometimes you allow for skipping of dose levels when you do
dose escalation, depends on the type of the agent you are investigating.
Sometimes, I personally don't like to skip dose levels,
at least I want to put some patients in every dose level
before we can go up. But those are all alterable depending on how you
want to do it. Flexible priors, because you don't really know how this
treatment works and what is its dose
toxicity relationship. So you can build in
different
assumptions using the built-in simulations.
The bigger issue comes in in how are you going to generate your high
dimensional AE data. So there are parametric and non-parametric data
generation. We have a platform for data entry and decisions after every
cohort, and we can actually use this
even as a vehicle to do an ongoing trial.
Now up until now, I'm really only focused on the
toxicity data that we are collecting on phase one studies.
And of course, when you have a good understanding of the toxicity burden,
then you can explore a little bit about the efficacy
on the set of dose levels that you think are tolerable.
But beyond that, I think what's missing in all of these designs is what is the
patient reported
or patient perspective on outcomes or on this
regimen. So this has nothing to do-- what I've showed this cartoon has nothing to
do with phase one trials, but we did a different analysis where we
administered a was it worth it questionnaire at the end of
trials. We simply asked the patients five questions.
Was it worth it for you to go on the trial?
Would you recommend this trial
to others?
So you can see thatThis has nothing to do, again, with phase one.
But really why I'm putting this cartoon up is just to show that
patients, it matters. What are the adverse events they get
matters. It's not the clinician-assessed adverse events, but patients.
These are chemo prevention studies. These are high-risk patients.
They're probably not getting the highly toxic
regimens that cancer patients are
receiving. These are still high risk, but not cancer patients.
You can still see
it mattered to them how much toxicity they got, how long they got this.
And depending on whether they got a lot of toxicity or not, their
experience was different. And why is this important?
Because if the experience is different, they're going to drop out.
In the chemo prevention trial, these were four weeks or five weeks or something.
This was in a phase two setting. These aren't the large chemo prevention
studies where we are following them for many years.
These were really simple aspirin for four weeks, things like
that. So even in those sorts of studies, when patients felt like they were
not doing well, they were not compliant.
They don't want to go on these studies. So it matters. It's very important.
Patient compliance and ability to stay on the treatment is the most
important thing for you to take when you go from phase one to phase two to phase
three, because that is what we are seeing.
A lot of the dose levels that you identify in phase ones
don't remain the dose levels in phase twos and phase three.
So you have to spend a lot more time in this early phase to get your foundation
right. So here is what our latest
collaboration design. So we
not only are incorporating this multidimensional adverse events, the
CTC-AEs that all of us are familiar with, and efficacy, but also the
patient-reported CTC-AEs. So
this is kind of the schedule. So you treat patients every
four weeks. Cohort one starts, at the end of four
weeks, you have cohort two. This is just a cartoon of the schedule of
how the trial could run. And then every four weeks you have, let's
say, a DLT assessment. How is the toxicity on this for
this cohort of patients? Let's say every eight weeks you have an efficacy
assessment, whatever it is, tumor shrinkage, biomarker levels,
are they alive, vital status, whatever it is.
Some sort of an efficacy readout.
And then these circles are what I mean by saying you can also get
information from the patient on their CTC-AEs.
Now, maybe every two weeks or every week is maybe too often.
You can make it as every
four weeks when the patient's in the clinic.
But really what this is trying to show is there's another dimension to this data
collection. So you have the dose administered, you have the DLT assessment, you
have the efficacy assessment, and you have the PRO assessment.
So this design just came out. It is in press.
So we really don't have a trial with this design. It just came out.
So this one has really three phases if you think of it.
So we have a dose escalation phase, which I talked
about. And I think Ying and others are all going to talk about BOIN.
So we use BOIN too in this one. Dose limiting toxicities.
You have a toxicity stopping rule.
We didn't use the toxicity profile, by the way, for the CTCAE, the TTP.
We used that for the PROs, actually, on this one.
Then you have the dose optimization,
where you want to assign the doses that you identified,
the ones that are the most efficacious.
Then you have both dose limiting toxicities and responses.
You have both the toxicity and a futility stopping rule for response.
But really, the last step is what was most important, because we didn't incorporate
the PROs, the toxicity, in the first two phases.
It was really in the final dose recommendation.
So once you have the toxicity
understanding, you have that this has an efficacy readout.
Now you have all this PRO CTCAE data that you've collected.
So now you can do a last function. You can really look at the trade-off between
efficacy and PRO CTCAEs, and you can figure out what the
right dose should be.
I
think I'm on time. I can't really see the
timer from here. But really a take home message is, I think the early phase
trials has
volumes of data that we don't always focus on.
So let's do a better job of looking at the multidimensional toxicity data we are
collecting, the efficacy PROs. Let's do a dose finding, dose
optimization, and a final dose recommendation.
Let's mimic the real world setting because not all patients are going to remain for
the six cycles. There's so much patient compliance and drop out.
So we have to
remember to account for that. And finally, of course, at the
end of all of this, what is most important is we have to have
good overdose control. We shouldn't treat patients at unsafe dose levels.
So that's my last slide. Thank you very much for listening, and I'm happy to take
questions.
So very interesting talk. Thank you.
So my question is about using the TTP model.
You showed that over time, increasing number of cycles,
toxicity increases. Was that cumulative?
Yes.
So not unexpected, but is there a way of
analyzing that data to see
if the slope of change
is lower as you go on suspecting that in your first
population, there may be people who are maybe genetically susceptible
to toxicity, and then begin a search to see
if there's some polymorphism like there is for some
cancer chemotherapy?
So you want to incorporate it during the dose finding, or once
you identify the dose to figure out are there different slopes for different
subgroups of patients?
Okay.
So that can be done.
So actually, maybe I didn't describe it well.
So let's imagine
you have significant toxicity out of the first
group-
Yes
... 20%. And then it's just a couple of percent
increase as you go up. So there's clearly a population at
risk.And to then interrogate those
patients to see whether they have like the UGT
polymorphism-
Yes
... that exposes people to get topoisomerase inhibitors,
they get tremendous toxicity.
Absolutely. I think that can be incorporated, right?
What I showed was just
one example of how the slopes can change.
So the way I showed you was it was linear, right?
Going from
one cycle of exposure, two cycles of exposure. So I just put it like this.
But yes, you can say that it's not that way, right?
It probably becomes like that as you increase-
Right
... the number of cycles. Yes, that can be incorporated. Absolutely.
Can I ask a second question?
I don't know. Ming,
is that okay?
Do you have more time or?
Other people talk.
Yeah, you can. He's saying you can ask.
So your model looks at four weeks
for toxicity. So there are, for example, immune
checkpoint inhibitors where there are actually toxicities that don't occur
until-
In the first four
... well, 10, 12 weeks later, particularly hepatic toxicity.
How does the model adapt to that?
So the model is not first four weeks.
The model is first six cycles.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yes. Oh.
Hi. Thank you for talk.
Very interesting aspects. I want to ask about the PROs, how
we can integrate those in the early phase, because it's easy to say that we are
going to do the PROs to the patients.
We are going to collect that information.
But we know, and the fear that we can have is how
biased this can be because
we don't have a randomization here.
We are not comparing with a control arm.
We are going to get information that, well, maybe the patient is not feeling well.
Is this because the patient is progressing?
Is it because it's having more symptoms, because of the disease?
It's early phase. These patients are going to have a lot of-
Yeah
... workload to do it on, PKs, et cetera.
This can have an impact on PRO. So how can we minimize this?
How can we interpret this properly?
So
obviously we haven't put this in a trial, that's what I was going to say.
But the way we did the simulations, we used the
keynote study and the PRO CTCAE
data that was collected in that to do the simulations.
But to your point,
really the
collection of the PROs here is not any PRO, right?
It is only the PRO CTCAE. So there's a set of
60 or I don't know how many ever things.
So you probably identify, you give erlotinib, you're thinking it's going to create
rash, right? So maybe there is something that you want to collect a little bit more
from the patient perspective of the rash.
So I think it has to be a very informed PROs, not,
"Okay, let's just collect everything," and then I guess you won't be able to
figure out what you want to do with that data.
So I guess-- and also remember, the second step already
identified a set of dose levels just based on toxicity and efficacy.
So if your PROs are incomplete, like you said, everybody's
saying, "I can't take it. I can't take it," because they have comorbidities in the
phase one. Maybe you don't have to use that as much to make
a recommendation, but you have that information when you get to the phase two,
because what is happening in a lot of studies, right?
You identify a dose level in phase one, and that never remains almost
always the same dose in phase two, because you end up doing a multiple
dose reductions, multiple dose interruptions, delays.
So maybe you have a better sense of going into your next--
moving into the next setting,
what to expect.
Thank you.
Can I?
Hi.
Thank you very much for the talk. It was wonderful.
Do you consider in your model the pharmacokinetics information?
No, but instead of response, maybe there is a way you can incorporate
PKs instead of... So there's an option to have
a continuous outcome for efficacy.
So maybe you use your AUCs or your half-life or
something like that. It's possible, but we didn't necessarily say that
it's a PK parameter.
Thank you.
Thank you. Oliver Rosnak, CombiBio.
I want to follow up on the previous question about PROs because I
have been always a big advocate for this and used it in
early trials, but I think there's more and more now concerns, as it was
mentioned, about the burden also just from PROs.
And so maybe I read too much into your comment about the chemo
prevention study, but that was pretty interesting when you
said little amount of questions.
Yes.
And yet people perceive this very differently because it
could have to do with literacy and other aspects.
And so have you thought about how to distinguish in such
a clean setting, so to say? Because the points were well taken about
advanced disease in phase one studies.
But if you have a chemo prevention study, then other things probably matter
more to you than doing whatever can be done to control your
cancer. So do you have any thoughts how to control for the
burden itself versus the adverse event?
No, because like I said, the data that I have is in the prevention setting.
It is very clean, right? So even if they were getting low
dose aspirin,
and then they have headache for two weeks, they think, "Oh, I don't want
to do this," right? Because I don't...
But we have a lot of PRO CTCAE data that's collected
in advance in phase threes and late phase trials.
So perhaps that's the space we have to look to see what is the
burden on the patient, and what sort of responses are you getting for the type of
treatments they are receiving, right?
What I was using the chemo prevention just to say it's important to incorporate
patients' perspective on these studies.
Yeah. Maybe the headache comes from all the documentation and the additional
assessments that are required.
Again, for the burden, I'm not advocating let's do 15 questions every two
weeks. That's not the goal. The goal is really to understand why-Or the
doses that you find in early phase trials don't remain the
doses as you go forward, because there is an important aspect that we are probably
missing. One is cumulative toxicities, and one probably is a patient
perception, not just a physician perception.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you.
So for my talk, I focus more on the
practical application and considerations here.
So,
it's my pleasure talking here. So, the title is
"Revolutionize in Phase I Trials Using the BOIN
Framework and Backview.
Certain Implementation and Regulatory Feedback." So, in the
context here, actually,
we have
used the BOIN as our default approach
in the context. So that's why I've gained a lot of experiences
engaging with agencies, how they think about this.
We're going to focus more on the FDA and
PMD's configurations in the early phase trials.
So a very quick review, where we are in for this talk, I
focus on the CBT part here. So this is the IND overview,
and for the IND considerations. So when we do
the first in human, you go through this process.
Either you get a clinical hold, which has a problem you have to resolve
before you enroll patients or seek to proceed. Right.
So safety, as we all know it, is ultimately
important for first in human trials because the first time the drug
is used to patients.
So there are a lot of guidance for that.
So I just bring in those IND from FDA perspective.
So FDA also has a guidance regarding expansion cohorts, how we
use that in first in human trials to expedite the
development of oncology.
So there are a lot of flavors actually from this, and we conduct the
first in human trials primarily following those guidance.
So certain points I want to highlight here,
for first in human expansion cohorts,
common major risks we are seeing. So if you have rapid
enrollment, then we expose large number of patients to
investigational drugs. So that's why we have a limit as we know it.
And it would may expose patients to suboptimal or toxic
doses and a misinterpretation of preliminary
results. Those are the major points highlighted in this guidance.
That's why we're considering some study designs in how do
we minimize the risks on those.
We need to assess
the safety, anti-tumor activities, PK/PD, everything
here as we do it. We must have a clear scientific
rationale why we do this and for what kind of patients.
Pre-specified stopping rules and sample size justification, all those
things typically considered to protect patients.
So let's go back to the Phase I and Ia dose-finding
designs. So here's a quick review of the history.
We used the 3+3 design for many years and
originating for cytotoxic agents.
Later on, you can see here we evolve over time.
In 2015, BOIN paper was published.
So
this is
our focus today using this approach.
And, so largely speaking, we have a rule-based
approach and a rule-assisted approach.
So the BOIN design belongs to the category of
model-assisted approach.
We can enjoy the
model
best fitting as well as the operational convenience.
So as a background here, so BOIN design,
FDA has determined that the statistical methodology of the local BOIN
design
under the naive informative prior is suitable for
fit for purpose designation in 2021.
So that's a major milestone for this methodology to have a buy-in
here. So we have a quick survey regarding
the usage in reality. So we can see here BOIN
has been used in all different categories and
therapies. Again, this review was based on 2022.
Right now, even more trials are using BOIN design right now.
So a quick review about the performance of this methodology
here. This is the primary comparison
between the BOIN and a 3+3. However, they are also
showing
MTPI as well.
So we can see the three performance here,
and on the top is about the correct chance of a
selection for the dose
and with targeted toxicity rate 15% and then
20%. And BOIN stands on the top, and it's the
bottom two
categories is for 25% and a 30% target DLT
rates and still performs
generally on the top.
So in addition to the correct selection, we look at the risk of
underdosing.
We can see here the risk is the lowest in general as the
bottom line.
So
there is also some flexibility here I want to mention.
This design providesGreat
flexibility allowing
any pre-specified target DLT rate.
And this is very important because when you run a
pediatric trial, for example, you may not want to have very high
target toxicity rate.
So you can adjust this target
toxicity rate based on the specific clinical settings.
And furthermore, unlike the three plus three design, where escalation,
de-escalation can only be made when you have three or
six evaluable patients here. Now, BOIN design does not
impose a fixed cohort size requirement.
As we know this, when we really run the trial,
once patient assign informed consent, and we're
obligated to treat them. So at that moment, you may have more
than
three patients, you may need to have certain
flexibilities.
Then the BOIN design provides this merit.
So here's how we really implemented this.
So it's very straightforward, to be honest, very
simple. What you're going to see is you have the
escalation and de-escalation boundaries, lambda
d and a lambda e.
So these two boundaries will tell you whether you should
de-escalate or escalate or maintain.
If you're in this interval between the lambda d, lambda e, of course, you
maintain that, otherwise, you de-escalate or escalate.
So very straightforward. And we're going to calculate the DLT rate for
the current cohort according to
number of patients who experience the DLT versus total number of
patients treated on that dose level.
And you also will see a table summary like this
regarding the boundaries here. So I circled the 0.25 for a comparison
because that's typically people use that.
You can see here the de-escalation boundary, for example, would be
0.298, and escalation boundary is
0.197. This means that in your
current DLT rate estimation, if that
rate is over 0.298, you're going to de-escalate.
If that rate is
greater than 0.197, you escalate.
It's very straightforward.
So here it shows the specific
cohort size decision-making here.
This
table shows three to nine patients
evaluable and treated. And if we set the target toxicity,
for example, 0.27 here, and you would see
when you observe zero out of a three, you escalate, right?
So that's called escalation row over there, and for the
de-escalation row, if you observe a two out of a three, yes, you
de-escalate. That's why for the first column there, and it
is consistent with the traditional three plus three
design.
So this target toxicity, you can choose like 0.25.
Actually, that table almost the same.
So there is
excuse me. There is another consideration for trial stopping at the lowest level,
and I would like to share that PMD is very
careful on this one. Actually, they ask a lot of questions.
So the thing is,
you could have a design. What if your lowest
dose ever is already too toxic?
So then how do we prevent that? So we cannot come up with a study
design that expose patients like that.
So that's why the BOIN design imposed
toxicity rules specifically for the lowest level, and we could
choose more stringent toxicity control on that.
If you observe excessive toxicity from the very beginning, then we stop the
whole trial.
So this table is for that purpose, for stopping rules.
Now, those are applications and performance in general.
And then this slide, a little bit of statistics, what's
inside of this methodology here. So BOIN
stands for Bayesian Optimal Interval Design.
So what happens is the target is to determine
lambda e and the lambda d, the targeting interval boundaries here.
And as you categorize your DLT
rate and according to where it is. So that's the whole thing.
So then the algorithm and mathematical model is really to
determine the optimal boundary, lambda d and the lambda
e. That's why we have the word optimal here.
So there are some extensions, but one extension I want to particularly mention is
about the
efficacy considerations.
In the original BOIN design so far, we keep talking about safety, but for
efficacy, there are some extensions like BOIN 1, 2, BOIN ET, and
U-BOIN. They use different approaches to incorporate
efficacy information into the decision-making.
So as we know that, right now, most of the therapies are targeted
therapies, and
DLTs actually are not common to see.
So toxicity may not be
major considerations. So efficacy plays a role when we
determine this dose. And usually, we also change the original
wording like MTD, maximum tolerated dose, rather
what we're really doing is to determine the recommended phase 2
dose.
So in practiceSo the efficacy in points,
something like a tumor shrinkage, and is a
more golden standard in the early phase setting.
We take a look at the shrinkage, whether there are activities.
However, there are some other endpoints I also want to mention here, some
emerging endpoints like sequential liquid biopsies
and radiomic changes,
such as the tumor growth rate, the PET, the
ctDNA, all those things will give you
insights how the drug
activities are
in the early phase settings.
So time is the essence. We cannot wait for a PFS or
OS whatsoever to make those assessment for sure.
So I cited several papers here. This is on ESMO's paper
for considerations. There are a bunch of recommendations for trial designs
in theirs.
The other one is a tumor growth rate and recently published and
very impactful
considerations for the early assessment as well for
activities.
So from the ESMO paper, we have some statistics considerations
in the first-in-human trial design.
Flexibility is the key in first-in-human trials.
And the backview is a major consideration.
We're going to cover a little bit on that later on.
So we also may allow interpatient
dose escalation, so-called IPDE.
So we need to develop certain criteria when you can do that.
EMA actually and quite
researching questions on this topic, actually, so
in our practice.
So the backfilling strategy is also a major extension for the BOIN
design framework. Recently, there are two methods available.
It's called a BF BOIN and a BE BOIN pair.
So they have different ways to incorporate the backfilling
patients.
So some late onset of toxicities can also be incorporated.
We can also incorporate PK
parameters. As a matter of fact, many projects, those
justification is rarely
based on PK, to be honest, because PK is
so
useful for these considerations, actually.
And so this graph shows some extensions, what
they are, and how they can be useful for different settings.
Next, I want to flip the page, talk a little bit about the PMD
considerations on those. So FDA
particularly raised this point, evaluates the scientific validity
in the context of
through simulations here. And the Japan PMD
released the initial CTN, that's Clinical Trial Notification
requirements for those escalation designs.
They require extensive simulations to be conducted
to evaluate the operating characteristics.
The 30-day CTN checklist and the early considerations,
those are two major documents were released in December 2024.
So I have some screenshot here for your information.
There are detailed requirements.
When you enroll patients from Japan,
you will expect to provide extensive
simulations to understand whether patient safety
is adequately protected.
So for application here,
I take it as a screenshot. It's provided by MD Anderson.
We're using this constantly. Certain functionalities are not
available, so we do have our own customized
considerations to address agency's question.
But generally speaking, this R Shiny App is very useful and
is also reproducible when you set the randomization
seed. So our statisticians love this.
Now,
I would like to share considerations when we really
use this R Shiny App for
application in the context of agency's
questions and inquiries, how we address those.
So the first section, when you really implement the BOIN design here,
you need to determine your target toxicity parameter.
Now,
in some protocols, 0.03 was chosen
as a target toxicity. However,
FDA came back to us saying this is too high.
So you have to be prepared, and you choose the right target
toxicity level. Do not make that too high.
So particularly,
excuse me,
the de-escalation boundary will become
0.359
if you choose target toxicity 0.3, and that is
too high in general, so we should be careful on this one.
However, when we choose 0.27, then we're able to lower the
de-escalation boundary to 0.322, and
agencies are generally okay with that.
Of course, if you choose a 0.25, it's also
acceptable.
For pediatric trials, hematology trials, you could even choose even lower
target toxicity, like 0.15 or 0.2,
depend on the settings.
So the next bucket I want to circle here is in the regulatory
consideration as well.
So when your target toxicity is lower
than
0.3, for example, 0.25 or something, then
the modeling will actually tell you if you
observe one out of threeSo you
deescalate or something, but
agencies are okay to override this rule because
the long-term transition using one out of three, and also
statistically makes sense because you only have three patients.
Too much variability. So they are also okay if you observe
one out of three and then you maintain the same dose level.
So
accelerated attrition is a major consideration
implication. So generally we recommend to use that,
unless you really cannot use. Okay, so we use that for one
or two dose levels to accelerate the development.
This next slide shows the
overdose control. There are two different mechanism control.
The first one is for so-called elimination rule, which means
if you find one dose level is too toxic, then you're going to eliminate
all dose levels,
including the current dose and above.
Yeah. So the
second one is the default cutoff.
There's a cutoff for the
first dose control, and maybe we
can set more rules on that, because primarily
from PMD considerations. So PMD, particularly
look into your lowest dose level simulation situation, whether you have
adequate dose control if you enroll patients from Japan.
Then at the end of the day, we use the model to find MTD.
However, that MTD level should not be over the de-escalation boundary
by common sense.
All right. So this is accelerated attrition design.
Just to show you here, the first two dose levels
design is accelerated attrition, which means we only enroll one patient.
If we observe
a Grade 2 above AE for this patient, then
we expand, otherwise, we're going to escalate.
So there has been agency interaction discussion about this.
So FDA is actually quite stringent on this.
They don't want to consider Grade 3.
They want to see Grade 2. In addition, they don't want to see Grade 2
must be
related to the drug. No, you don't have to.
As long as you observe a Grade 2,
you may want to expand number of patients on that current dose level.
So those are the considerations when you really implement this
in the real practice.
Now, we're going to
touch quick basic because the time here, so how many minutes do I have?
Three.
Three minutes, okay. Thank you. So, just some quick
points regarding the back-filling BOIN design here.
So back-filling has been widely used in practice but often in
ad hoc way in reality. And we don't
have a very clear criteria for back-filling in general,
historically, and how to adjust the dose escalation if
excessive toxicity observed during the back-filling, for example.
And the SRC, the Safety Review Committee, or
sometimes called a Dose Escalation Committee, decides the next dose level.
However, whether back-filling patients, how they
do this,
how they incorporate it into this, has been a mystery completely based
on
personal judgment.
So this is the merit here for back-fill
BOIN design that can help. And so provides a principle
to rigorous approach that can address those issues and safeguard patient
safety, and also can guide the SRC for
decision-making process as well.
So the back-fill design, I want to just clarify the criteria here.
One is,
you have to determine what dose levels are eligible for
back-filling. So there are two considerations.
One, the dose must be cleared for safety.
And two, there should be
able to demonstrate the activity.
So you don't want to put a patient in harm's way, as well as
treatment benefit.
Let me see here. Okay.
I want to... Okay, I mention one thing here.
Because you do the back-filling, there is a small chance you may
have some conflict decision-making, so the conflict
resolution is through pooling. So basic idea is to pool
patients together from multiple dose levels and to see the
situation. So there is specific resolution how we achieve
that.
This is examples where now they use
the BFBOIN design and into the
algorithm calculation for the dose
modification there.
So just for example, for your reference here.
So finally, this last slide, take-home messages.
The BOIN framework, combined with structured back-filling, offers
a practical and regulator-acceptable way
to Phase 1 oncology trials and improves dose
finding efficiency and its allocation to potential therapeutic doses
without compromising safety. And provides explicit guidance of
recommending the dose level to SRC rather than relying on completely
personal judgment. So implementation experience and regulatory
feedback indicate that BOIN is transparent, easy to
operationalize, and increasingly supported
when we have clear decision rules and simulation
justifications, and a robust safety oversight.
This conclude my talk.
Thank you.
With the time, maybe we
We have six or eight minutes
All right.
We still have
five to eight minutes for questions, if we have.
If not, I don't...
All right.
Okay, so I'm going to give a last talk, and
Dr. Manjarka and Dr. Ki have covered
phase one, dose funding. And I will more focus on phase
1B and phase 2 setting. So in that case, we have more complete
coverage of early phase trial.
And in phase 1B, sometimes we call co-expansion or dose
expansion or phase 2. One critical design question we have
is how we monitor those patients, both for safety and
futility. Right? So if the treatment is
toxic, we want to stop early. And if futile, same reason,
we want to stop. Of course, in some case, we show superior
efficacy, we may want to move that
drug into phase three as quick as possible.
Okay, so this is my disclaimer.
And,
so my talk going to have two parts. The first part will
give you a very brief introduction about the Bayesian statistics and the way
the statistical foundation, statistical monitoring, is going to be used
for toxicity and efficacy.
So in January this year, and many of may know, the
FDA and also EMA issued a draft guidance and a
concept paper on use Bayesian methodology to modernize clinical
trial. So this is a paradigm-shifting event.
And to use
FDA commissioner's words, okay, so this is a leap forward
beyond our conventional frequentist approach.
And Bayesian methodology help address two biggest problem
of drug development, high cost and long timeline.
And this modern statistical method will help sponsor bring more cures
and a meaningful treatment to patient faster and more
affordability.
And Bayesian, for a lot of non-statistician, it sounds
mysterious and magic. And actually,
it's pretty simple, and we use it in our daily life.
Okay, when we are attending a conference, one of the most important
decision we have to make is to where have dinner today.
And how we do it, typically what we do is we will first do some
search and read some review, and then we will pick a restaurant.
Right? And then we went there, and sometime we like it, sometime
we don't like it.
So that forms our posterior opinion.
And the next year or next day, you may go there again or never go there.
So this is exactly Bayesian thinking.
So we have a prior opinion before we go to restaurant.
And then we go to the restaurant, and we collect data.
And we may like service there, we may like food there, we may not like.
And we use that to update our opinion about that restaurant.
We may go again or never go again, or we can recommend to friend.
So if you do it in this way, you are Bayesian.
Okay, so here is more formally how we summarize
the difference between the conventional, so-called frequentist approach and the
Bayesian approach. So in frequentist approach, we assume the data
is random and the parameter is fixed.
For example, we want to understand the safety, we understand the efficacy.
The toxicity rate and efficacy rate, they are fixed parameter.
We're trying to estimate based on the data.
And we make such estimation or inference based on
data likelihood. And the Bayesian take it the opposite way.
So in the Bayesian, data is fixed because we already observed the data.
It's fixed, never change. Right? And the parameter is
random. And we want to do is we want to infer what's
the true parameter looks like based on the data we observed.
And statistically, we do it through the Bayes' theorem, which show that's the
bottom. So we form our posterior opinion or understanding
of the parameter based on our prior opinion and plus
the likelihood. And the one real nice thing about Bayesian is you
can continuous apply this philosophy, continuous update your
opinion. So for example, you have your
original prior opinion. You collect the data, you get a posterior.
So think about you are a physician, you treat patient.
You treat the first few patient, you have more understanding about that treatment.
And you may think the drug may safer or not safer,
or it can be suitable for certain type of patient.
So once you have that opinion for the next few patient, that's your prior
opinion. And you treat more patient, update your understanding, and you can
continue this updating process, continue learning.
So that's one very powerful
feature of the Bayesian statistic. We learn as we go.
Okay, so in here, we're going to focus on how to use Bayesian method for monitoring
in phase 1B and 2 setting. And Bayesian are particularly
suitable for this task for several reasons.
And firstly, it can provide an actionable metric.
I'm going to show you on next slides.
And the second is can seamlessly integrate diverse data source
enable a truly totality of evidence approach.
And then lastly, it can
enable dynamic learning. So we can always form our
new prior and get the data, update our belief in a continuous
fashion.
Okay, so I'm going to use example to demonstrate how can we use Bayesian to make an
coherent decision-making and toxicity efficacy
monitoring. So let's consider single arm trial, and we want to
compare experimental drug against the historical control response rate of
30%.And then here, what we are interested in is true response
rate for the experimental drug. And we collect some data.
We treated 30 patients, 14 response.
And if we take a conventional approach, we will say, okay, estimated the
response rate is about
46.7%. And if you are even better, you will carry a
confidence interval, which is 0.317,
2.616, and you can get a P value,
0.07. So that's all you have.
And if you look carefully, so those estimate does not really
provide a direct measure of evidence for you to make a go, no-go decision.
Right? So what we really want to know is, given the data, what's the true
response rate? It's greater than 30%.
It's 40% chance greater than 30, or 80% chance, or
90% chance better than the historical control.
So that's exactly Bayesian inference can tell us.
So we start in, let's say, before we collect the data, we want
as objective, as
subjective as possible. So in here, in statistics, it's called
non-informative prior. So when you look at the left-hand side, so
x-axis is response rate from zero to one.
We give any response rate equal prior probability.
They all equally likely happen before we collect
the data.
Then we collect the data. We treat 30 patient, we have 14
response, which showed as a likelihood in the bottom.
And then we combine that prior with likelihood, get our posterior
understanding of the response rate.
So this posterior probability contains all the information
regarding the data contained about the response rate.
So, for example, from this distribution, we can understand
the ratio likelihood of any response
rate.
For example, in here, the 40%, given the data,
40% are at least three times more likely than
30%
in terms of response rate.
And more intuitively, it also allow us to calculate what's the probability
the response rate greater than 30%.
So what you do is just calculate that area under the curve.
So in this specific case, when you observe 14
response out of 30 patient, this
probability is 0.976. That means there is
97.6%
of chance that the response rate is greater than 30%.
And it can also give you
what's the likelihood the response rate greater than 30%, greater
than 50%. So you can ask any question you want,
and it also can ask you what's the likelihood the response rate
belongs to a certain interval.
So, for example, in this case, we can calculate the
probability response rate between 40% to 60%, it's
71.3%.
And if you want, we can also come up with a similar point
and interval estimate as a conventional approach. Right?
So you want to know what's the point estimate response rate.
In this case, it's 0.47, and it also can give you
a
credible interval, which is 0.327 and
0.613.
So based on this, you can see the Bayesian
naturally leads to a very
easy understand rule to monitor toxicity and
efficacy.
So in the top, it shows if the response rate, given the
data, if the response rate greater than 30%, it's less than a certain
cutoff, then we're going to stop accrual for futility.
And the C is a pre-specified cutoff.
And similarly,
a Bayesian rule can be constructed for toxicity monitoring.
So let's assume the 40%, it's the toxicity rate.
We want to have a high probability of stopping the trial.
And then we just can directly kill, given the data, what's the chance
the true toxicity rate is less than 40%?
And if that probability is very low, then we may stop the
trial for safety. Right?
So in this very intuitive toxicity monitoring rule,
and the key parameter from design perspective is how to choose the
appropriate cutoff C.
So that's the way the Bayesian optimal Phase 2 design
can help, and which provides a highly efficient and unified
framework for futility and toxicity monitoring.
So it use the following, information dependent cutoff to
balance two competing requirement.
So one is when the treatment is futile or toxic, we want a high
probability stop. And when the treatment is effective or
safe, we want a low stopping probability.
And in the bottom shows this information dependent cutoff.
So here capital N, it's the maximum sample size, and the small n
is your interim sample size. And you can think that fraction
essentially represent how much information you have so far.
And
this cutoff, it's a
function of the information you have.
And here we have two design parameter we have to decide.
One is lambda, one is gamma. And in the BOP2
design, it use a statistical optimization, determine
those two parameters such that we maximize the
probability of a correct decision, which you can also call it power.
And the BOP2 also belongs to a model
assist design, which means its decision boundary can be
pre-tabulated, provide a simple lookup table for clinical
implementation.So here I give you a very simple example.
Think about that trial for the 30 patient, and we want design that trial.
And we want to incorporate both toxicity and the safety monitoring.
So our plan is based on clinical consideration, also operational
consideration. We want to monitor toxicity after every six
patient, which showed in the left table, and you can see 6, 12,
18, and so on. For futility, we just want to have
only one interim look, which is the middle of the trial, and I put the
15 and the 30. That's at the end of the trial.
And if you go through that optimization problem, use the
BOP2 design, it will leads to the decision table as I showed at the
top.
And for the person implement trial, you don't have to worry about those
optimization, those posterior probability calculation.
What you need is those two table, and you can look up the table, make a decision.
So for example, after you treat the sixth patient, if number of toxicity greater
or equal than C3, you should stop the trial for safety.
And if less than that, you can continue.
You know, additional 6 patient, reach 12 patient.
And among that 12 patient, if toxicity greater or equal than
five, the trial should stop. Otherwise, you can continue, and so
on. So on the right-hand side, that's the same logic for the
efficacy monitoring. And in the bottom, that shows
under each criterion what exactly the design
parameter or decision boundary you have.
So this design going to ensure when the true toxicity rate
is 20%, there is about 85%
chance we're going to claim this treatment is safe.
However, if the treatment toxicity is 40%,
we only have 20% chance claim it's safe.
That means we have 80%
chance correctly identify that treatment it's not safe.
On the right-hand side, that's for futility.
Okay, so BOP2 compare with some conventional
design. I think many of you ever
did a phase 2 design. You will know Simon two-stage design.
So compare with those conventional design, BOP2 offer substantial greater
flexibility than those traditional approach.
And it allows investigators specify monitoring time and the
frequency based on clinical priority or trial logistic.
So here, which I shows an alternative way to design
the trial example. So for example, if you
think I monitor every
safety after every sixth patient, logistically, too much burdensome, what
you can do is you monitor toxicity for the first six patient.
After that, you do less monitoring because it's already show it's quite safe.
You don't have to do that frequently, and you can monitor after every
12 patient. So this result into the table on the left.
So you're going to monitor toxicity after 6 patient, 18 patient, and the
30 patient. And again, you can get the
stopping boundary a priori and put in the protocol.
When you do the trial, you don't have to do any calculation.
You just look up the table, make a decision.
And from the right-hand side, it shows, okay, I want more efficient because I'm not
sure about this drug effective or not.
And if it's not, I want to stop trial as soon as possible so I can use
my resource for other drug development.
And in this case, you can add one more interim monitoring.
So we can monitor futility after every 10 patient, 10,
20, and 30. Again, you can see the boundary can be
predetermined based on statistical optimization.
And also
BOP2 also move beyond the simple boundary crossing
to provide interpretable and actionable measure of
evidence and the support a totality of the evidence approach.
So for example, we showed in toxicity monitoring,
and if we
treat 18 patient, there are six toxicity.
And when you look at the table, decision boundary on the right-hand side,
it does not cross the stopping boundary.
That means you don't have to stop the trial for toxicity.
But you may wondering, it's so close to the boundary, how safe the treatment
is. And you can immediately calculate, right?
So in that case, when you observe six toxicity out of 18 patient,
so we can calculate based on that data, the
probability true toxicity greater than 30%, it's
0.665, and the toxicity greater than 40%,
it's 0.308.
And on the other hand, if the toxicity crossed boundary, for
example, 18 patient, you see eight toxicity.
In this case, we know we should stop the accrual, but we still want to
know how strong the evidence the toxicity is.
And again, you can easily calculate it.
In this case, the toxicity rate greater than 30%, it's
0.196, and the probability toxicity rate greater
than 40% is 0.667. And so
that give us much more a totality of evidence
approach to determine what we should do next, right?
So maybe you may
modify the formula to reduce toxicity so you can move this
drug forward.
And also, BOP2 design seamlessly handle deviation from a
pre-planned interim schedule without compromise the trial integrity.
So this, especially when we do the trial, a lot of time, we have planned the time.
For example, in the
futility monitoring, we
planned take a look after every 10 patient.
But in practice, we may often over-enroll or under-enroll patient.
And here, Bonan give a example. If we accidentally
enroll more patient, we end up with 14 patient rather than 10
patient. In this case, we still can calculate what's the chance
the true response rate less than 30% or greater than 40%.
And this now enable us to make a
decision.Okay.
So
we developed this website called trialdesign.org,
and we put a lot of tools there, and BOP2 is one of
them, and also BOIN is over there.
And so this allows us to generate that decision table.
So for the user, you don't have to worry about those complicated statistical
calculation and optimization. So if you go to BOP2 Suite, and then
you click it, so this is what it looks like.
And when you select the BOP2, this is the
interface of that software. And here
I'm zooming in. And so for example, you want to design a trial,
and you want to do a feasibility monitoring, and you have a binary
efficacy endpoint response or not response.
And you're going to specify your interim time and based on
logistic and the clinical consideration.
So in here we put the 10, 20, 30, and then you enter what's the
response rate, your non-response rate, under which you want to stop the trial,
and also your alternative response rate, which is your target.
So in here, let's say 30%, it's pretty low, and we want to stop
the trial. 50% is our target response rate.
And we also want to control the false positive 0.1.
And once you click it, and it will generate the table for you,
and this is the decision boundary you can incorporate in the protocol used for
trial conduct. And
also it allows you to run simulation study to
generate operating characteristic.
And so you can understand the presenter to the team, how it looks like when the
true toxicity is 25%, 40%, 50%, what's the
chance the trial going to stop.
And also once you did that, the
software will also generate a protocol template for you.
And so this is one example. And in
this protocol template, it will
incorporate a statistical
foundation behind the methods and what decision
rule looks like statistically and also the decision
table, and also incorporate the operating characteristic, the
simulation you have conducted.
So this is typically, it's good enough for IRB
review and
FDA submission. And generally, they are happy with it.
We don't have any issue
so far.
So it also allows you to choose a different scenario.
And for example, if you want to also do toxicity monitoring, and you
can choose the toxicity to your interest, and they specify the interim time.
And again, you specify the non-toxic rate under which you want to
stop the trial, and alternative, which means the drug is safe, you don't want to
stop the trial. And they put the error rate you want to control,
and they will generate the stopping boundary.
In this case, when you have six patients, three or more toxicity, you should stop
the trial. And otherwise, you can go to 18 patient
and make the decision again.
So this is the
protocol template generated by
the software. Again, it's a complete package,
including decision rule, statistical rule, and
operating characteristic.
So the design itself, due to time limitation, I mainly focus on the
simple setting. We just monitor binary toxicity
and binary efficacy. And
the methods itself, it's highly flexible, can handle more
complicated clinical setting. So, for example, its idea
in a trial, we want to monitor toxicity and efficacy
simultaneously.
And you can do that, selected your endpoint as
efficacy and toxicity. In other words,
we only continue
if the drug is sufficient, efficacious, and safe.
And in this case, it will create the joint boundary
for
toxicity and efficacy joint monitoring.
And even notice here, like for response for the second column, there's
N/A. So this
build intention because it allows you have a different
timing for toxicity and efficacy monitoring.
So in general, we prefer more frequent safety monitoring than
futility monitoring. So it allows you to do that.
It also can allow you have a more complicated setting.
You monitor multiple efficacy endpoint.
So, for example, you have a trial,
and ORR may be not the most reliable
indication for efficacy. So in this case, you may look at
ORR and PFS at the same time. So in this case,
as long as the treatment show a promising signal in
one of the endpoint, you can continue the treatment.
And in this case, you can choose multiple efficacy endpoint, and
it will also generate the stopping boundary for you.
And it stop when only both efficacy endpoint
satisfy certain condition. Otherwise, you will continue the
trial.
Okay. So this is the last slide, and the Bayesian
posterior probability provide an intuitive and flexible approach
to monitor toxicity and efficacy.
And in particular, we introduced a Bayesian optimal phase 2 design,
BOP2 design, which is a model assist design that
based on Bayesian posterior probability, but it offer a
very easy to implement, highly flexible and efficient
way to design cohort expansion and the phase 2 trial.
Okay. That's all I have, and I'm happy to take any
questions.Yes.
Hi, I'm Esteban Rodrigo from DB Pharm.
The question is about... Because this is really interesting, of course.
It's something that we have tried to apply to the clinical trials a lot of times,
to try to find a way that we can monitor how the expansion is going
to do, when we are going to stop earlier to not enroll more patients.
The problem that we have a lot of times is that, okay, we don't want to stop the
enrollment for a long period of time.
We need to wait to have at least one scanner per patient
on those 10 patients. That means that we need to wait at least eight weeks
until all of the patients have had a scanner.
This is
a lot of times a problem because waiting that time until we can get
the analysis, it's not ideal. So we are going to stop
the enrollment several times. If we don't stop enrollment, we can be in a
situation that at the time that we are going to perform the analysis, we have
enrolled 10 additional patients.
So it's always the same issue. So how can we
mitigate this?
Yeah. So that's an excellent question.
That's a very common logistical issue, and there's a couple way to handle it.
One is you can utilize some more advanced
methods. So there is a
extension of BOP2 design. And what it works is it's
based on current data. It's going to predict those pending patient, what's their
potential outcome going to be. And then based on those predictive value, it'll
make decision should it go, no go. So in that case,
it allow you make a real time decision, when some patient outcome
is pending.
But the approach,
I think it help to certain degree. Let's say at a certain point, you only have one
patient. You
enroll the 10 patient, only two patient have outcome, all other pending.
In this case, you predict eight patient out of two patient doesn't make sense.
So in practice, I think what you can do is combine that methodology with
some control of accrual.
Thank you.
So,
if you're using this design in a
randomized Phase 2, let's imagine a platform design.
You have a control and multiple arms.
How can you adapt if the control arm outperforms what
you had previously predicted? So there's been a
shift over time, and so instead of the response rate in
control, which predicted to be 20%, it's actually
35%. Is there a way of
actually evolving your
endpoint for your experimental arms
in real time as you're going along?
So sort of doing a Bayesian design on the
control to
shift... Because again, if you have a 40% response
rate, which was your target, but your control was 35%, you're probably
less interested in the new treatment.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you, Mark.
In the platform trial, I see two
issues that I think quite relate what you said. One is the shifting of the control.
Right? And the other is the treatment. And both can be adapted.
And imagine what we calculate every time is the,
given the data, what's the probability
the treatment response rate greater than the control?
So that control can be also based on data, not have to in here, for example, for
simplicity, I fixed it at 30%. But that can be based on the
concurrent or in trial control data.
And,
so that means the benchmark compare with can adapt over time.
If both change, it's changed. So in that case, what do you vary?
What's the chance the treatment going to beat the control arm?
And, so that's one. And secondly, if there is a really change
and you want to raise your bar. For example, in that case,
when you compare with treatment and control, typically we have a certain margin we
target. You want to improve at least 10% or 20%
and so on, or even your control arm changed because a new drug
approved. And in this case, you can adapt it, plug in the right data,
condition the right data to do that calculation.
So,
the
designs that you showed
were for single arm, but there could be an-
Yeah. But it can easily use for two-arm trial, right?
Because again, just 30%, it wouldn't be 30%.
It's going to be the response rate of control arm.
Right.
When you calculate that posterior probability.
So you'd actually be doing it on the delta, not on a fixed...
Yeah. Exactly.
Thank you.
So if you go to our software in that suite, there is called a
two-arm BOP2, which exactly handle the case you have a randomized
two-arm trial.
So any other question for any of the speakers?
Hello. First of all, it was great talk. Thank you very much.
Very helpful. We heavily used your tools and software
online. So just one question in terms of the
program. So we use for study design all these
tool, but when it comes to FDA submission, so in
terms of program validation, do they accept directly
from your tools, or do we have to independently program in
our or other softwares just as a double
validation?
Yeah. So, so far, most of our software, it's
focus on early phase, and we never had a issue, FDA come
back and say, "Okay, you have to validate,
somehow demonstrate the validation of your software."
And actually,
we validate it. It's just then you need to show evidence or not.
Actually, last week, and we have a
trialAnd
so that trial was not designed by me, by someone else.
It lacks toxicity monitoring. And the FDA actually, in
their comments, they give a suggestion, use this
Bayesian toxicity monitoring. And then they even showed the OC, they
say, based on the trialdesign.org.
So,
in general, and of course, that's one case, but
our general experience is
we never had the issue
to use software for regulatory submission.
Okay. Thank you.
But phase three trial, yeah, we have not. Yeah.
Software yet.
Thanks for the great comments.
Are there any cases where an informative
prior has been used?
You mean for monitoring
or for in general?
Or anything. It could be for safety in a-
Yeah.
For safety, I guess, primarily.
Yes.
If you look at
FDA general guidance, even in the
registration trial,
especially when you handle pediatric or rare disease, they allow
you use informed prior to borrow information to
assess the efficacy of the treatment.
And in the early phase, I think it should be much easier. They will allow it.
But even in the registration trial.
I think right now,
regulatory more open for such information borrowing
for
rare disease and the pediatric trials.
Thank you so much. I like the
org website. So the open source part of it is pretty
fascinating.
My question is, what happens when we push the
boundaries, we go to phase three?
Let's say we want to stack the Bayesian algorithm, so we want to
also look into patient satisfaction,
patients' biology,
pharmacogenetics.
How do you envision building upon the Bayesian
model but moving from phase one to phase three?
Yeah.
So guidance talk quite a bit about it, and
I think the agency is looking for
a
comprehensive, robust operating characteristic in your
submission. So in other words, you use Bayesian.
Typically, when we use Bayesian for couple of main reasons.
One is borrow information. That's what Bayesian really
the strength is. And also you can use that to
measure the evidence. Rather than use P-value, you can say, what's the
posterior probability the treatment is better than the control?
Based on data, it's 99% chance. Okay.
In general, compare with conventional approach, you just
represent P-value, that's it. But for Bayesian, you have to do more
extensive evaluation. You have to use simulation to demonstrate
under different cases. So for example, when you borrow information, right?
So what we really worry about if there's a prior data conflict, the
information you borrow is not consistent with your current trial information and
intuitively create a bias. And you want to show how much bias you
may create, and your method is
general robust under the range, which is
realistic in practice. And
that's, I think, more for the confirmatory setting.
And for the early phase, for a long time,
in general, I think regulatory have a lot of flexibility on
that.
So I do see more and more chance we can leverage
those normal Bayesian methods to make
trial more efficient.
Yeah, the key is, I think, work one of us.
Work with the statistician, then you should be getting your take care.
Okay, any
additional question for any of us?
Okay, if no, thank you, everyone and